das bist du herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine damen und herren zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal und ihr
seht es bereits im titel eingeblendet
sandra spielt sandra spielen heute gut
los
susanna das hier bist du die ziele und
die musste ich war warum trägst du jetzt
schon fest wir haben das video läuft ein
paar sekunden dass andere diese ziege
bist du deine linke hand muss an die asd
immer wsd alters finden da kannst du mit
laufen eher wundern recht an hier an die
maus bitte dann kann sich damit um
gucken und jetzt der kunde einfach mal
das spiel klar kurzer spiel was mozart
gibt es hier in der aktion oder was du
da laufen durch die gegend alter also
bei gott simulator gibt es eigentlich
keinen richtigen sinn also es ist jetzt
nicht so dass du irgendwie levels
bestehen muss und so weiter und sofort
an es gibt ein paar challenges die du
machen kann braucht man wieder honda das
ist nicht mein kraftwerksleiter geht es
darum dass du all diese ziele da bist du
da gerade steuer saß du wurdest
guckt euch mal um
du wurdest überfahren
[Musik]
mit wsd kannst du ganz normal rumlaufen
kannst du die welt einfach mal ein
bisschen anschauen wenn du die linke
maustaste drücken machst du so einen
kick
manchmal genau gesagt dann kannst du
sachen zerstören beispielsweise jemand
dazu dem auto links das hier das ist ja
das sind dinge die du einsammeln ganz
ich glaube ich bin wieder nein jetzt ist
auf jeden fall wieder draußen einem
stelldichein
die frau seinen stuhl und drückt man
linke maustaste genau dann kannst du
sachen kaputt machen die explodieren
lassen und so weiter und so fort
ich bin nämlich in einem zwiespalt in
welchem zustand ich checke das spiel
nicht ich laufe mit einer ziege rum und
was machst du spaß daran
das ist kein zwiespalt sondern immer
nach links gehen dass die richtigen ich
kann fliegen
ich kannte das macht mir jetzt schon
keinen spaß
du machst du scheiße hat irgend einem
vernünftigen orten genau drehe ich jetzt
mal um neun in die hand die andere das
ist doch ein anfang wenn ich dir dabei
zugucken
bevor wir gleich direkt weitermachen mit
guernsey later möchte ich allerdings
wieder eine person auf instagram pushen
und zwar den user - sh xt die person hat
dieses team hier gepostet und mich
darauf markiert was steht auf dem
grabstein eines mathematikers damit
hätte er nicht gerechnet als auf den
bildern oder ja geht so warte auf jeden
fall alle gerne
danke dass du mich auf dem bild markiert
hast wenn ihr auch ein schau dort im
nächsten video bekommen wollt dann
verlinkt laser luca auf euren in seinen
bildern und jetzt ich bin weil die leute
haben einfach mal irgendwohin genau wie
man zur tankstelle beispielsweise da
kann es mal hin laufen nach vorne links
genau den ex links gucken muss dann
rauskommt
mit der linken maustaste wenn du vor dem
stets mit ihm sprechen
sprachen lernen deutsche sprache schwere
sprache
jetzt geht auch beispielsweise mal zu
der tankstelle hin die ist ja genau und
in die tankstelle kannst du unter
anderem auch reingehen also du kannst
auf sala einbrechen und so zur
tankstelle ja dass er das spiel macht
mir absolut kein spaß jedoch meine
tankstelle vom klatschen diese ressel
denn immer gegen alle sachen also
dagegen läuft egal so förster
jetzt steht auch auf dem gefährt genau
genommen gar nicht klappt mit der
kontrolle was macht ihr da bekomme ich
davon weg und musste raus laufen du
kannst auch base drückt man kann zu
springen übrigens dann kommst du über
gegenstelle weil die kinder so dein
tastatur es sehr g oder was ist also
nicht was es bedeutet ein
für mich ist leertaste leertaste
springen doch jetzt mal darüber die
gegenstände drüber und dann links durch
die tür aus ja ich bin zu dick eindeutig
sprungkraft gleich null die gaskammer
du musst weh und springen drücken dann
springst du nach vorne genau
und jetzt hast du links durch die tür
wieder rausgehen aber erst nach der knie
alles sondern ganz einfach rausgehen
also die einfach mit w wie genau dann
bist du wirklich zum fels drei wochen
später
hey ich bin einfach zu dick eigentlich
wusste das hilft nicht weiter
[Musik]
weil du musst aber irgendwie raus kommt
jetzt ja okay jetzt wissen schnell
rauskommen kann die tankstelle weg war
ich dass ich glaube ja du kann ich kann
die sich in einer sekunde die ganze
taktik zerstört und der typ für
wahrscheinlich immer noch was kaufen
denn die vorleger einfach so eine echte
ziege im echten leben wird einfach
tankstelle zerstören alter junge du
wirst prominentes weiter
es ist noch ein richtiger laufen einfach
jetzt ein bisschen langen kommen
beispielsweise in einer rechtskurve da
sind ganz viele leute versammelt da die
da die demonstrieren irgendwie fehlen
was nein links sie da jetzt wieder
rechts genau da kann es jetzt mal mit
space drüber springen genau und jetzt
gucken dich an du kannst mit dem
protestieren sandra gehe nie den weg
weil du dir einen angriff machst du hast
übrigens noch eine andere funktion und
zwar kannst du mit dinge anleger rücken
genau und jetzt laufen 1 noch einmal
drücken genau nochmals drückt nochmal
genau und jetzt wer als jetzt kannst du
rumlaufen und hat jetzt kann sie eine
person oder eine drückt habe ich mit dir
sowas zu spielen macht gar keinen sinn
also noch mal thema zu einer person hin
und er stellt sich vor eine person genau
davor eine person
ich hoffe mal wieder fest ich denke habe
ich wechsele ich heiße bewusstsein geben
einfach mal zu einer person hin ständig
vor die person ganz langsam vor die
personen laufen sandra vor eine person
mit segeln jetzt drückt genau und jetzt
wieder wer es serum laufen und dann hast
du mich eine person die dranhängen und
kann sich quasi mit ziehen unter steckst
schon wieder fest ich für das spiel
genial ich dachte dass minecraft und
fordert mit dir stemmen gewesen wäre
aber trotzdem älter sprengt den rahmen
alles hinter dir also drehte ich noch
einmal komplett um genau läuft man den
weg da lang nach vorne da wo die beiden
karten stehen nach vorne veranstalten
die leute nämlich einen grillabend grill
bratwurst ohne durch ein paar sekunden
später genau sondern die leute hier
vorne machen begriffen hat die tanzen
die ganze zeit rum und du warst nicht
eingeladen
[Musik]
wie soll ich dich auf einem bildschirm
spuk war ja das heißt jetzt nicht so gut
hingekriegt jetzt lauf und jetzt
springen und dann bist du im
das geht nicht weil dies zudem kalt da
ich als ganz genau wie du dich fühlst
also das ist der pool leider kein wasser
drin weil die hatten kein geld dafür da
wasser zu halten aber das sind
trampoline und da kannst du genau hier
nochmal drauf
kannst du wenn du dreimal space also
genau und jetzt kannst du space rücken
dann kannst du kannst
[Musik]
danach erwarten die stadt dorfen
trampolin drauf junge mit dir dieses
spiel zu spielen ist unfassbar wie
vielleicht nie los du fliegst jetzt erst
mal eben das top-team warum weil du
nicht getroffen hast was kann man die
ich mache ich erstmal spotter alto hast
du dir ein elektroschocker gesehen das
war dein kopf der im trampolin ihm
stecken geblieben war dort an da hier
vorne ist eine rutsche da sind wir jetzt
angelangt
du kannst diese rutsche theoretisch
einfach mal runter rutschen jetzt mal
hin genau sehr gut du schaffst es nicht
mal eine rutsche runter zu rutschen
ja ich hab noch nie mit pc gezockt aber
zwei seiner mutter die rutsche runter du
bist du auf der rutsche
und letzter neben dem mülleimer
weil das leben gefällt mir richtig gut
alt du bist die ganze zeit hin und her
zwischen du magst da spiele ich dann mag
es ist doch wieder da ist es doch nicht
so genial da sitzt es doch wieder kacke
keine ahnung was das auto
mein leben hat einen führerschein aber
ein leute weit alles praktisch und so
mache ich so lange sich das lied in my
mom g
an der schule wird mir das heute geht es
allerdings am band laufen
an der gründung und ich mach blogs die
app v
ich wollte noch ein auto machen ja mach
abonnieren war ein kanal falls noch kein
teil der lose seien dadurch verpasste
keine videos mehr ich heiß auf instagram
laser luca sandra lessau finsterem self
in braunau die geister aus ganz
deutschland eu west ihr wisst bescheid
manners und du hast auf youtube auch
sandra alexander jetzt nämlich blogs
hoch oder videos jeden donnerstag und am
sonntag
und ja
[Musik]